we're running out of time you've seen
what's happening out there
five
[Music]
I can handle Thomas show up eventually
that's what I'm afraid of
they took you because you're immune
the plague that's wiping out the human
race they think you're worth sacrificing
to find a cure will never stop totally
stop them the last city rickets the
whole base of operations mr. meyen
standard model as people lose on three
years we spent behind wolves trying to
break out now we're trying to break back
in alright I get shotgun
the world is dying
if we find a cure that's the only way
all this was worth it to aggress or you
just host I did what I thought was right
there's no guarantee we make it back
from this don't we stop this together
things where I'll end up that way too
you still care about it down here to
Miami
I'm gonna Cates believe the roundup
torture kill when the hell does it stop
it stops holy find a cure
[Music]
Thomas you can save your friends or you
can save us all
[Music]
please
you